The version of Captain Marvel that hit theaters
was clipped-down and polished-up, missing
a handful of scenes you'll wish you got to
see on a 50-foot screen.
Here's a look at all the scenes that didn't
make it to theaters.
While she's living on Hala and going by "Vers,"
Carol pays the Supreme Intelligence a visit
and sees it as Mar-Vell, aka Dr. Wendy Lawson,
the Kree scientist with whom Carol worked
in the U.S. Air Force.
Yon-Rogg accompanies her to the meeting, but
the finished film doesn't show him having
his own encounter with the A.I. overlord.
Since the Supreme Intelligence appears to
its guest as the person they most admire,
when Yon-Rogg meets with it, he naturally
sees the spitting image of himself.
"We both know your admiration is mostly reserved
for yourself."
The Supreme Intelligence chastises Yon-Rogg
for the failures of his mission six years
prior, from killing Mar-Vell to not retrieving
the energy core she built, and leaving Carol
alive as a supercharged liability.
The usually cocky Yon-Rogg is shaken, and
begs the Supreme Intelligence to allow him
to kill Carol to make up for his mistakes
a proposition the A.I. denies.
"Bring us the core and the girl — alive,
Yon-Rogg."
Of all the film's deleted scenes, this is
the one that co-directors Anna Boden and Ryan
Fleck have said they wished made it to theaters
the most.
Speaking to CinemaBlend, Boden said,
"I think the scene where Jude visits his Supreme
Intelligence is really fun [...] Jude Law
is playing both characters and being both
brutal and vulnerable in the same space."
One deleted sequence features Yon-Rogg lecturing
a group of young Starforce hopefuls about
the Kree Empire's mission to protect itself
from the shapeshifting Skrulls.
Yon-Rogg teases the recruits about potentially
being shapeshifters themselves before turning
his attention to Vers, calling her the best
example of Kree potential.
Vers then enters the room and shares her own
disdain for the Skrulls.
"The commander's right about the Skrulls.
They took everything from me.
My home.
My family.
My memory."
She also calls attention to the implant in
her neck, which she still wholeheartedly believes
is a good thing, and the source of her powers.
"Our leader the Supreme Intelligence saved
me, gave me purpose, and this implant, so
I can fight back."
Early on in Captain Marvel, the members of
Starforce fly to Torfa, a planet on the border
of the Kree Empire, to locate and rescue the
missing Kree spy Soh-Larr.
The expedition ends up a total failure when
the Skrulls successfully snatch up Vers as
part of a trap.
Before things go south, the movie was meant
to include some light-hearted banter to send
the Starforce gang off on a happy note.
One deleted scene shows Vers joking around
with Minn-Erva, Korath, and Att-Lass, who
tease her about a previous mission to which
she brought a little too much heat with her
Photon-blasting fists.
"That was not my fault, we were specifically
told to bring the heat."
"It was very hot."
Minn-Erva, calling her by the name of "Twinkle
Fists," gives her a sarcastic piece of advice:
think with your head, not your hands.
The fun momentarily stops when Yon-Rogg arrives
and reminds them of the task at hand: bring
Soh-Larr home to Hala safely.
Bron-Char manages to sneak in one last quip
as the Starforce team is loading into their
containment vessels:
"Does anyone else get claustrophobic in these
things?"
In an extended version of Carol's interaction
with the man on the motorcycle, things get
kicked up a notch after he asks her for a
smile.
First of all, we learn that Vers isn't the
only character in the scene with a weird name.
"I'm Vers."
"People call me The Don."
Instead of a grin, Carol asks if he's up for
a handshake.
He obliges but she uses her fiery fists to
burn his hand, leaving him helpless in her
alien grip.
"Here's a proposition for you.
You're going to give me your jacket, your
helmet, and your motorcycle, and in return
I'm going to let you keep your hand."
The scene may have been cut for making our
heroine appear a little bit too much like
Marvel's own Terminator which may have been
an intentional reference, considering the
shared ‘90s setting.
As the now-in-pain Don hands Carol his keys,
she places a sassy cherry on top of their
conversation:
"What, no smile?"
Ben Mendelsohn gives a chameleonic performance
as Skrull leader Talos.
While audiences still think Talos is a villain,
he shape-shifts to disguise himself as Keller,
the ‘90s-era Director of S.H.I.E.L.D.
What follows is a cat-and-mouse game between
Talos, Carol, and Nick Fury.
One scene that got snipped from this plot
shows Keller attempting to track down the
Quadjet Carol and Nick stole from the Air
Force Academy.
"So you're telling me you can't track your
own plane."
Since the plane has anti-radar tech, there's
no way for Talos to immediately locate it
— which means he's further away from discovering
the truth about Carol, Wendy Lawson, and the
location of his family.
But when another S.H.I.E.L.D.
agent hands Talos some intel on the crash
site and Maria Lambeau, his chances of cracking
the whole thing wide open greatly improve.
Speaking of Talos, another Captain Marvel
scene you didn't get to see reveals what happened
to the real S.H.I.E.L.D. director after the
green-skinned Skrull stole his look.
It would have played out right after Talos-as-Keller
says goodbye to his fallen Skrull comrade,
the one who Nick Fury killed while he was
impersonating Phil Coulson.
Things end there in the theatrical cut, but
the deleted scene keeps going, making sure
it's clear to everybody that there's some
shapeshifting going on.
Out in the hallway, the true Agent Coulson
passes by Nick Fury, and offers to be his
partner in the ongoing investigation.
Fury rejects him.
"Here's that police report you're after.
Need a partner?"
"Not now, rook."
Trying to prove himself useful, Coulson jumps
at the chance to help Keller get into his
office — not knowing it's actually Talos,
who forgot to grab Keller's I.D. card when
he first took his form.
Who's the rookie now?
Coulson happily swipes his key card through
the scanner on the wall, granting Talos access
to the real Keller's office.
There, we see the S.H.I.E.L.D. director on
the floor, bound and unconscious, and watch
as Talos grabs Keller's badge from underneath
his jacket.
Unlike some of the other sequences, it makes
sense why this scene was cut.
The only people it would play as a reveal
to would be viewers just getting back from
the bathroom.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.